[knocking on door]
[emotional music continues]
[Barb] Who is it?
It's the Mormons.
[Bob] For the last time,
we're not converting!
["Curls" by Bibio playing]
♪ To see within
Is to feel without a light ♪
♪ Who'd have thought
That we'd break the things we like? ♪
♪ To find a stone
Just to bounce across the pond ♪
♪ Is the path it makes
That's a clue to other songs ♪
♪ Her hair, it curls
In the depth of the night ♪
♪ The scent recalls
Like a photograph with life ♪
♪ Her hair, it curls
In the depth of the night ♪
♪ The scent recalls
Like a photograph with life ♪
♪ To live without
Is to live under a spell ♪
♪ Who'd have thought
That we'd turn our home to hell? ♪
♪ To find a bone
And to float it down the stream ♪
So, what do we do now?
-Kiss her, you idiot!
-[Josh laughs]
♪ Her hair curls
In the damp of the night ♪
♪ The scent recalls
Like a photograph with life ♪
♪ Her woolen coat
Under yellow sodium lights ♪
♪ Records the air like a memory of night♪
♪ Her hair, it curls
In the damp of the night ♪